LEE KEENER: Hi,
ladies and gentlemen.
I'm Lee Keener.
I'm the general manager here
of the food team at Google
Chicago, and it's
my distinct pleasure
to introduce you
to someone who's
followed a very unorthodox
and fascinating journey to get
to us today.
What was once a scholarly
path as a political analyst
in Washington, DC,
where she hoped
to support her Mexican homeland
with stories of a culture
and food history,
but she couldn't
stop thinking of the food
that she had from her youth.
I once read that you said food
means love, nurture, family,
all things warm and
good in the world.
Cooking is your way to show your
love of food and your devotion
to your loved ones.
I hope that some of you guys
are as fortunate as-- there's
some people in the world
that the career chooses them,
and then they never work
a day in their life.
So this unorthodox path--
it led to her very own PBS
show specializing
in Mexican cuisine,
and for that, she's been awarded
with a finalist for the James
Beard award, which we held
here in Chicago this year
in just a couple weeks
at the Lyric Opera House.
Very exciting.
Congratulations.
PATI JINICH: Thank you.
LEE KEENER: And so as
the unofficial ambassador
of Mexican food, hers is
a story of her life's work
and her courage to pursue it.
So ladies and
gentlemen, Pati Jinich.
[APPLAUSE]
PATI JINICH: Thank you.
Thank you, thank you so much.
In Mexico, we have a saying.
When somebody says
nice words about you
or they give a
nice introduction,
you say they've given
you a bouquet of flowers.
That was a gorgeous bouquet.
Thank you.
LEE KEENER: Thank
you for coming.
PATI JINICH:
Thrilled to be here.
I know everybody in
Google is a foodie,
because I know you're so lucky
to have such incredible food.
And so yes, I think that the
food that I make has changed.
So what I'm presenting of
late in this book that's
called "Mexican Today," and
it's funny-- you have to tell me
when to start cooking, because
I'll just start talking.
But so at some point, if
you want to see me cook,
just say, Pati, cook, OK?
And I'll start cooking.
So anyway, everything that's
in that book sort of, I think,
represents what Mexico,
Mexicans, Mexican cuisine
represent today, like
where we are today.
And I think we tend to
put cuisines in a box,
and I think that happens
even more so with Mexico,
because we're such close
neighbors-- you know,
the US and Mexico.
We think we know each other
very well, and I for one
can tell you that I
know that it's not true,
because I am a Mexican, who
thought that I knew Mexico,
and I thought that
I knew the US.
And as the years
go by, I realize
that I keep on
learning and learning
and still don't know much.
So when I first got
to the US, I used
to think, oh, Mexican cuisine
is this bounty of centuries
and centuries of mother
cuisine that is so rich, so
rich in history and legends and
traditions, which is all true.
But I used to think that the
food in the United States
was younger, that
there wasn't that
much of a regional
diversity or variety.
And as I've been in the
US now for 18 years,
and the more I'm
here, the more humbled
I am to see the food
that exists in the US,
not only regional
American cuisine, but also
the way that Mexican food
is evolving in the US.
And I'll get to the enchiladas.
I promise I'll start.
But what's happened to me
is the same thing in Mexico.
Every time I go back to Mexico,
and I studied Mexican history
and politics for years.
I did a thesis that was this
big, this big that took me
three years, and it was
about Mexican federalism
and-- I know-- the relationship
between independent governors
and the federal state or
the central government
from 1810 to 1996.
And I traveled throughout
the Mexican republic looking
for that information,
and so I thought
I knew Mexico very well.
And every time that I
go back to Mexico now,
I realize that I
think I know a place,
and I think I know a
region, but Mexican cuisine
is like a growing,
evolving animal.
It keeps on evolving.
It keeps on changing, and
the things that we thought
were traditional and would never
change keep on being updated.
Traditional recipes,
luckily, stay, persevere,
keep on being passed
on from generations,
but new things, crazy
things are happening,
which is very exciting,
because new air brings
space for breathing.
So in this book-- and I'll get
to enchiladas-- in these book,
I have a combination.
I have what we call the
rediscovered recipes,
where went and found
regional recipes that are not
that well-known in the US and
in some areas of Mexico as
well, but then some new things
that I've taken the liberty now
of making in my kitchen.
So that takes us to the
enchiladas, and I'll start.
LEE KEENER: We have
them going in the back.
We're taking care of you guys.
PATI JINICH: Yes.
So the enchiladas that
we're making today
are shrimp enchiladas, which
also go by entomatadas.
Are you familiar
with enchiladas?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PATI JINICH: Yeah.
I'm in California, right?
No.
I'm in Chicago, which is even
more-- So enchiladas go also
by the name of the sauce, so
here it's called entomatada,
because it has a tomato sauce.
And OK, I'll start making it,
and then we'll keep on talking.
OK.
So you know what enchilada
means, the word enchilada?
LEE KEENER: I don't.
PATI JINICH: OK.
So enchilada-- I know I was
supposed to start cooking.
OK.
I'll start cooking, I promise.
Enchilada is when you dip a
tortilla in a sauce that has
a chili in one way or another.
So that's what we're
going to make now,
and the sauce that we're going
to make that has jalapenos,
has that chili.
It's not spicy.
So what we have--
see, I started.
So what we have here,
what we have here is
they helped me prep
with everything.
So here, I'm just going to
add a little bit of oil.
Help me.
Oh, you [INAUDIBLE].
Hi.
Come on in.
It's been 20 minutes, but I
haven't started cooking yet.
I'm kidding.
OK.
You guys had to have
the cool gadgets, right?
LEE KEENER: We have some
pretty cool stuff here.
PATI JINICH: OK.
So we have the oil.
I'm adding a little bit more.
And what we have here is the
sauce that your team already
prepared, which was some
boiled ripe tomatoes,
which you have here in Mexico.
We tend to use the Roma tomatoes
for the sauce or very ripe
tomatoes like you have
there, because we want them
to be mushy and really
juicy and not firm
at all when we use
them for the sauce.
And we boil--
well, they boiled--
like a pound of Roma
tomatoes or ripe tomatoes
and some garlic and a
jalapeno and serrano chili.
I know here in Chicago,
everybody knows the differences
between for chilies, right?
You guys.
We should just start eating.
No, I'm kidding.
OK.
So they use, I assume,
serranos, which is what's here.
And the serrano
chilies tend to be
spicier than-- oh, beautiful.
And jalapenos.
Yay.
So you have the jalapenos
and the serranos.
I'm on purpose letting
the oil heat a lot,
because what I'm
going to do now is
I'm going to season the sauce.
So we have the
tomatoes, the garlic,
and the chili that was
boiled for about 10 minutes
until very, very soft and
very mushy to the touch,
and then pureed in the blender.
And then you add some scallions,
some salt, and some broth
from the shrimp tails.
So I'm going to add it
here, and I'll tell you
about the shrimp broth.
And that's exactly what's
supposed to happen.
If you go into a Mexican
kitchen or a Mexican restaurant,
and you don't see
that-- fire hazard--
if you don't see smoke
and sizzle and splatters,
don't eat the food.
It's going to be terrible.
Usually, that's what
Mexicans are about is
a lot of reactions and actions.
So we have this, and it smells
like delicious shrimp broth
soup.
So we want that reaction,
because-- and splashes--
because we want this sauce
to react with the oil
and, therefore, sort
of fry in the oil,
and it's going to go-- I don't
know if you can see the color,
but it had sort of
a pale boiled color
like spring/summer
looking, and now it's
going to change to
like a fall, autumnal--
if my kids were here, they would
help me with pronunciation.
Autumnal?
Autumnal color.
So just deeper, it's going to
be richer, thicker, darker,
and you can see it changing.
And then we also added
in here shrimp broth,
which was made with the
tails of the shrimp.
You guys, when you
buy shrimp, get it--
and this is beautiful shrimp
that you all got today.
LEE KEENER: This is gorgeous
shrimp from the Gulf Coast.
PATI JINICH: Tell me about it.
LEE KEENER: It's off the Texas
coast in the Gulf of Mexico.
I was six years in New Orleans,
so I'm a snob about shrimp.
I love the Gulf Coast.
I think it's the best
shrimp that you can find.
So that's what we have here
today with the shells on it.
I think what you were
just about to say
was make sure that you get
it with the shells on--
PATI JINICH: Yes.
Tell them why.
You tell them.
LEE KEENER: This is OK, the
stuff that you eat every day.
Shrimp is delicious.
These shells-- these
are God's gift.
This is an amazing thing.
Don't get them already peeled.
Peel them, and then
learn how to use them.
You get a beautiful rich
red color to everything.
You get the smell.
It's a beautiful,
salty, briny smell.
PATI JINICH: True.
LEE KEENER: You get your
hands dirty a little bit.
PATI JINICH: Yes.
And then the best
thing about it is
that you have-- when you buy
the shrimp tail and shell on,
it's going to be--
it's going to get
to your table in better shape.
It's going to sort of survive
the transitions with much
more dignity, and then
it's going to be plumpier,
it's going to be
crisper, and then
you make a broth-- it's
very simple-- a shrimp
or seafood broth
either with the tails,
or if you were using fish, you
could make these with fish too.
Then just take the
head and the tail,
tell the fish monger to
not give you fillets,
to filet it if you don't
want to filet the fish.
But tell him to
give you the bones.
You're going to have
some gorgeous stock,
and then what happens is that
the filling of the enchilada,
which is going to be
these cooked shrimp--
do you want to help me on the
other side cooking shrimp?
LEE KEENER: Sure.
PATI JINICH: OK.
So you're going to
have an enchilada that
totally makes sense.
You're going to have
an enchilada where
the filling and the
sauce have been really
married or inter-married,
because the sauce is going
to have-- it's not
going to taste separate
from the filling.
Has that happened
to you when you
have something in the sauce like
doesn't connect to the filling?
LEE KEENER: Yeah.
It's not all together.
It's like when you take pasta,
and then you wash it off,
and you add it to
your sauce instead
of cooking it all together.
Absolutely.
PATI JINICH: Yes.
Exactly.
OK.
So here, let me borrow--
LEE KEENER: I'm making a mess.
PATI JINICH: OK.
So I make a mess, I know, and
this is such a beautiful table.
Here you go, for the shrimp.
And then what I'm going
to add to the sauce,
so what we have
here to sort of sum
it up was some boiled
tomatoes with boiled garlic
and a boiled
jalapeno and serrano,
and then always remember
to cook more chilies
than you think you want.
And then when you
puree the sauce,
add less chilies than
you think you want.
So say you boiled two
or three jalapenos.
When you puree the
sauce-- the tomatoes
with the garlic
and the chili-- add
one chili first in the
salt, and then you taste it.
If you feel like you need
more heat, add half a chili,
or-- is this like
too 101 for you guys?
AUDIENCE: No.
PATI JINICH: No?
OK.
Everybody's here so
expert in food in Chicago.
I've been amazed.
Tell them.
Since yesterday, we got
here, I've done nothing
but eat my way through Chicago,
and everybody seems like so
incredible and knowledgeable.
Anyway, I was saying about
the chilies, add one.
Taste for heat.
See if you want
more [INAUDIBLE],
and then add half more,
because you can never take
the spice or the heat away,
but you can always add.
And you already did your
sauce and your shrimp broth,
and then it's too spicy.
It's sort of a bummer.
You have to make the recipe
again without chilies
and combine it for the
heat to be turned down.
So we have the tomatoes, the
chilies, the garlic, and then
we added some of that
shrimp broth, which
had the tails and the
shells of the shrimp.
Very easy.
You put it in a saucepan,
cover it with water,
and then I like
to add bay leaves,
parsley, some garlic, salt,
let it simmer for nothing.
I mean 15, 20 minutes.
Let it cool down, and strain it.
You can put it in the freezer,
use it for a ton of things,
or use it for this.
You can add any
other herbs that you
like if you don't like parsley,
and then it was mixed here.
And now I'm going to
add some Mexican crema.
It looks so pretty.
Do you want the salt?
Tell them any tricks
for cooking the shrimp.
LEE KEENER: Don't
let it go too long.
Don't be afraid of
it being underdone.
Shrimp is one of those things
that I never order out.
I do it myself, because
everybody always overcooks it.
So many people are afraid
to eat undercooked items,
but everything goes up
the flavor mountain,
and if you cook it
too long, you're
going down the other side.
So I would-- just like you can--
PATI JINICH: That's
a great metaphor.
LEE KEENER: Thank you.
You can always take chilies out.
Same thing-- you can
always cook it more.
I'm the same way with chicken.
PATI JINICH: But you
can't take it back.
Once they're overdone
and rubbery, and then
even if you had like super fresh
shrimp, if you overcook them,
they're going to smell.
So you want them plump.
You want them crunchy.
I agree.
They're going to
lose all their charm.
LEE KEENER: I got the butter
just as it started to brown.
And I put the shrimp in.
You can see how all the
colors started on it.
And I flipped them over, and
I just turned the fire off.
I'm letting it sit.
You can still hear it sizzling,
so it is still cooking.
PATI JINICH: So you
want it over high heat,
but a short amount of time,
so it'll brown on the outside,
but it will stay crisp
and plump on the inside.
And even when you
remove them, they'll
still be hot from
the sear, and they'll
continue to cook a little.
So I agree.
And if you have
fresh shrimp, nothing
happens if you eat
them a little raw.
And they won't be raw
if you give them--
even if you give them
20 seconds on each side,
they'll be good enough.
LEE KEENER: These are ready.
PATI JINICH: They're ready.
Should we put-- in here?
Yes.
Oh, that's perfect.
So here we have the sauce,
and what I'm going to add now
is I'm going to add
nutmeg, and I'll tell you.
So this is salsa roja
or tomato-based sauce.
I've told you the ingredients
like 30 times, right?
Can I quiz you?
No, I'm not going to repeat
the ingredients again.
I was about to do it.
But aside from adding
the Mexican crema-- oh,
we didn't tell them
about the Mexican cream.
I know here everybody in
Chicago is an expert when
it comes to Mexican
ingredients, but are you
all familiar with Mexican crema?
Yay.
I can say something new.
Mexican crema is a
very fresh, thick,
salty-- I mean teasingly
salty, very tangy
kind of a cream that's like a
cousin of the creme fraiche.
It is, I think, thinner than the
sour cream and not as acidic,
but it has a lot
more personality
than the heavy cream,
which doesn't have
that tang and that saltiness.
Was that too complicated?
Mexican crema is just
its own ingredient.
You can find it everywhere,
especially here in Chicago.
It really makes a
difference if you use it.
If you can't find
it, you can use, OK,
fine, fresh creme, or if you
can't find it, instead of sour
cream, I would use heavy cream.
And then I'm adding
the nutmeg, which
I think is an ingredient--
I don't know if you agree--
that tends to be overlooked.
LEE KEENER: And typically,
it's already ground,
and ground spices are another
thing I'm kind of a snob about,
because they've been
sitting too long.
They get dusty.
They get that dusty flavor.
For instance, you mentioned
the fresh bay leaf.
This here is fresh bay.
I was so glad to see
the chef found this,
because I've been on him for
months buying fresh bay leaves,
because it makes all the
difference in the world.
You know what's on
your shelf at home.
That dry, pale green, dusty--
the flavor comes through.
The oils are still alive.
Smell it.
Go ahead.
Pass around my bay leaves.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Give it a little squeeze.
Smell it in your hand.
Pass it around.
You'll see the difference.
You'll smell like bay
the rest of the day,
and you'll thank me.
PATI JINICH: You know what?
I think you should pass
around your nutmeg,
because it smells incredible.
And the nutmeg is also adorable.
I mean, just look at it.
It is like a marvel of nature.
It's an adorable ingredient.
It smells incredible.
It tends to be used for
dessert and for pastries,
and as you say,
usually comes ground,
and it really
tastes like nothing.
But when you grate
it-- and it's also fun.
I think that for many people,
cooking-- and of course,
it has to happen.
I have to have
dinner in my kitchen
for my three boys every
day at 6:00 or 7:00 PM,
and we all get thinking that
cooking is this task that we're
going to have to wash dishes.
What am I going to cook today?
But when you have these
tools like how cool is this?
And it's probably
like $6 or $7, and you
can grate your own nutmeg.
It's like you start bringing
meaning and technique
and information into your
kitchen, and so your kitchen,
instead of being this place,
where you, oh, I'm a foodie.
I will really want
to eat, but I don't
want to clean up this mess.
When you start getting these
things into your kitchen,
your kitchen transforms into
this like alchemist's lab,
where you have these
tools and spices and yeah.
Yeah, that's what I think.
LEE KEENER: That's what I meant
by getting your hands dirty.
You said it a little
more eloquently,
but you get connected
with what you're doing.
It's not just a chore.
It's not just a way to eat.
It's a way to live.
PATI JINICH: I agree exactly.
And then also, it's
very interesting
when you start
sort of adopting--
I'm going to add some salt, and
if you want to add some pepper,
but we don't need pepper,
because we have the nutmeg.
I take it back.
So I'm adding some
salt to the sauce now.
You can make the
sauce ahead of time.
What you can't do ahead of
time is cook the shrimp.
Like you really want to do right
when you're going to do it.
Or you can eat them cold,
but don't reheat them again,
because they're not going to
be ready for your enchiladas.
They're going to be
ready for Halloween.
So we have the sauce.
I'm going to let it season a
little bit, and then what we do
is you're all familiar
with preparing the corn
tortillas for enchiladas.
No?
I'll tell you.
OK.
This is going to
make-- and you guys
have gorgeous tortillas here.
There's a technique
that has been passed on
through generations and
generations, and it's very.
Simple you have
the corn tortilla,
and all you need to do in order
to fill it, roll it, and then
sauce it, is to, what we say,
prepare the corn tortilla
to be dressed.
So because I really think
that the enchiladas are
like Mexico's most fanciest
way to dress and honor
our tortillas, because
tacos-- we all love tacos.
Everybody knows tacos.
there's tacos of all kinds,
and they're fascinating,
but enchiladas is like
when somebody tells you
you're coming home
for enchiladas.
Aren't you like, wow?
LEE KEENER: They're
running home.
PATI JINICH: I mean, it's
like it's something special.
It sounds like an
occasion, and you're
going to garnish
them and dress them,
and it's just a little bit
more fancy, even though it's
a simple, unpretentious dish.
It sounds-- so you
can serve enchiladas
where the tortilla has been
prepped, because if I roll it,
see what happens.
So I always say--
but I don't know
how you guys feel about this--
that for enchiladas, you really
need to use corn tortillas
and not flour tortillas.
What do you think?
LEE KEENER: What do I think?
To get more flavor
and texture into it?
PATI JINICH: No, like
are you giving them
permission-- I'm kidding.
Not that I can give permission.
But are they allowed to use
flour tortillas for enchiladas?
LEE KEENER: For enchiladas.
PATI JINICH: I say
corn tortillas.
LEE KEENER: Yeah, corn
tortilla for enchilada.
Flour tortilla typically
for fajita, tacos.
PATI JINICH: Exactly.
Flour tortillas are great
for tacos, great for fajitas,
great for quesadillas.
LEE KEENER: But if
it's good, it's good.
PATI JINICH: [INAUDIBLE].
But I say no flour,
so we're just
going to heat them
straight over the fire.
You can use a
comal or a skillet,
or you can pass them through
really, really hot oi.
You can do it straight over the
fire, or you had a comal too.
LEE KEENER: Yeah, you
can use that tray.
PATI JINICH: Let's use-- OK.
Like that, here.
The flour tortillas-- there's
a deep reason why you shouldn't
use flour tortillas
for the enchiladas,
because they're sweet,
because the flavor changes,
because they get really
soggy, because they're not
made to withhold or
withstand the sauce,
and they just lose
all their charm
when you sauce them
and then let them sit.
The corn tortillas
are resilient.
They also have--
their flavor profile
is much more nuanced,
because it's not that sweet.
And then see?
After chef heated
them, you roll them,
they're not going to break.
So I think we can toast
them a little more,
because the tortillas
are so fresh.
Anyway, so you
prep the tortillas,
and then we're going to
soak them in the sauce,
cover them entirely
in the sauce,
and then you fill
them with the shrimp,
and then we garnish them.
You can make the
sauce ahead of time,
and then when you're ready
to eat, you just reheat it,
and you stuff your enchiladas.
And you have an entire meal.
Let's prep one here.
There's also a basic
trick to making--
and then you can make
cute, adorable enchiladas
with the tiny tortillas
that you guys have here,
which the rest of
the US doesn't have.
Do you guys know how lucky
you are to be in Chicago?
It's like, yes.
Yes.
OK.
We can make some
cute small ones.
So we're just going to cover the
tortilla entirely in the sauce,
and you do that so that every
single bite of the enchilada
is worth your time.
You don't want a piece of the
enchilada, not a single bite
that doesn't have the sauce.
Oops.
I'm going to do it quicker.
Yeah, that helps.
Thank you.
OK.
Let's forget about
these ones, OK?
If that happens,
just add some cheese.
Add some crema, and eat it up.
OK?
Then we're going
to add the shrimp.
You can do it whole if
you want to look fancy.
When I want to make
my kids feel special,
I add the whole shrimp.
It looks like a fancier meal.
And then you fill the enchilada.
If you're like me, you make
the enchiladas way too chubby,
and then add more sauce on top.
I know you have spoons.
I keep using the tools
that I shouldn't.
Add more sauce, and
then you garnish,
so you use the white part of
the scallions to make the sauce.
So people say that
the French are
very frugal in their
cooking, but I think
that Mexicans are even more.
And then you garnish
with the green parts
of the scallions and some
queso fresco or queso feta.
You can add more crema.
That's not in the recipe,
but you can add more.
And then some
super ripe avocado.
LEE KEENER: [INAUDIBLE].
PATI JINICH: Oh.
I'm going to come for
dinner every night here.
You have everything prepped.
LEE KEENER: We just got
these in, these little
beeswax sheets, so
you're going to see these
in the microkitchens
for the sliced avocados
that you guys eat half
of them and then can't
use the rest of them.
I think we finally
figured out a trick,
so we're going to
start using this.
PATI JINICH: Wow.
OK.
What's the paper?
I've never seen it before.
LEE KEENER: It's beeswax.
It's a beeswax
sheet, and you can
wash it and reuse
it, and rather than
continue to use plastic wrap.
PATI JINICH: There you go.
So that's the enchilada.
So just like that,
I mean there's
like countless enchiladas.
I think in the chapter,
I have maybe like
15 different kinds
of enchilada, but I
think that's nothing
from what you can find.
So not only looks pretty, no?
Looks pretty?
You can find south
of the border.
You can find
countless enchiladas.
You can find-- I'll
give you examples.
So that's the entomatada
with the tomato
sauce with cream and nutmeg.
I have in there an
enchilada with mole verde.
You all know mole verde.
It's a mole made with pumpkin
seeds and lettuce and parsley
and cilantro and
tomatillos, delicious,
stuffed with pork tenderloin.
I have another one with
asparagus and mushroom
and thyme and goat cheese
covered in a pine nut mole
sauce.
There's one stuffed with crab
meat and peas and tarragon
and a sauce of jocoque,
which is hard to find here,
but you can make it similar
with buttermilk sauce.
So those are just
some-- so people--
LEE KEENER: Don't
get them hungry.
Look at them.
They're hungry.
PATI JINICH: --don't think
of just the Tex-Mex enchilada
or the salsa verde enchilada.
There's so many.
I have one-- oh, this
is my kids favorite.
But no, this is my kids' number
one enchilada, the number
one that they love the most.
The second one is the
pork with the mole verde
sauce and pickled radishes,
and the pickled radishes
take like five minutes to make.
And I was saying
what was my favorite
for my kids-- black
bean enchilada.
I have some enchiladas that I
call the big brunch enchiladas.
They're stuffed
with scrambled eggs,
and then they're baked
with a black bean sauce--
super rich-- seasoned
with chipotle [INAUDIBLE],
and then you garnish
with pickled jalapenos.
I'm a fan of pickled jalapenos.
Are you a fan of
pickled jalapenos here?
Yes.
You can use the ones
you can find here
in Chicago too, the ones that I
just tried in the Chicago style
hot dog.
You can use those too.
You guys, those
were good hot dogs.
Anyway, and then
avocado, and then
I also fry and crumble
Mexican chorizo,
and then I add that on top.
So you can have breakfast,
lunch, brunch, dinner
enchiladas.
Just don't use flour
tortillas, and that's it
for the enchiladas.
LEE KEENER: And we have
some coming for you.
Is that where [INAUDIBLE]
just go to get them?
So we're going to be putting
out some things for you to try.
In the meantime, does
anybody have any questions?
PATI JINICH: Any questions?
My kids aren't here, so I
can talk about anything,
because they're
usually embarrassed
about one, my accent, and two,
the responses that I give, so.
AUDIENCE: Have you
always liked cooking,
or is this something where
it evolved over time,
and you developed that love?
PATI JINICH: Yeah.
I mean, it is something
that has really changed
over the course of my life.
I used-- I'm a very
opinionated person,
and I used to be a very yes,
no, always, never, love, hate,
black, white, and
with time, I've
realized that things mostly
fall kind of a gray thing
that one day you may be
really good at something,
but in five years,
you realize that you
were good at something else.
I always loved eating, always.
I am the biggest eater.
It's a prob-- like,
isn't a problem?
It's a problem, and
we just met yesterday.
I mean I just-- I'm
obsessed with food.
Like that's how I experience
the world, you know.
And so I've always
loved eating, but I come
from a family of four girls.
I was sort of the
tomboy growing up.
We always loved eating,
and my three sisters
got into the food
world-- I'm giving you
the longest answer possible.
My three older sisters
got in the cooking world
very early on.
My oldest sister
became a caterer.
My second sister became a
pastry chef, French trained.
She's like-- they're
all incredible.
The next one became
vegetarian, then vegan,
and now is also into
fashion, so she writes about
like healthy,
fashionable lifestyle.
I was like the
intellectual sort of,
and I wanted to be an academic.
I trained as a
political scientist.
I worked in a think tank.
I kept accidentally bumping
into food-related things,
and I absolutely loved them.
But I always yanked myself
back thinking your expectations
and people's expectations.
If I already invested
this undergraduate degree
and this graduate degree, I
need to go in that direction
until one day, I had two kids.
I had my third on
the way, and I really
didn't like my job at a think
tank, which is a great think
tank in Washington, DC.
But this is how I
changed careers.
My boss asked me if I could
write a policy analysis
paper comparing the transition
to democracy in two countries--
Mexico and Peru, like both
really complicated topics.
And I was researching
those, and I
had a colleague
who was Peruvian,
and he kept telling me that
his Peruvian ceviche is
so incredible.
And I was like, no, Mexican
ceviche is so incredible.
And he was like,
no, we had it first.
I was like, no, no, no, no.
We had it first.
So instead of researching
on the troublesome path
to democracy in
both countries, I
started researching who
got to ceviche first.
And I was like--
it was like a week
that I was deep into research,
and when the Spanish arrived
to where, and when
the Portuguese
arrived where, because
everybody was eating raw fish.
But the question was,
who added citrus first?
And there was no citrus
in Latin America.
So I was like so fascinated,
and after a week,
I went to my boss, who's
now a really good friend.
He wasn't very happy
when I resigned,
but we're really
good friends now.
And I was even more
guilty, because there
wasn't a job position in
that think tank for me when
I applied, but I really thought
that that was my dream job,
so they made a position for me.
And after like a year
and a half there, I
felt I've been here so long.
They made this position for me.
I can't just go, so like
for nights and nights,
like for a year and a half,
I was like, I could do this,
I could do this, until
finally, I resigned.
And I went into cooking
school in Washington, DC,
thinking I would do
not political analysis,
but sort of gastropolitical,
gastrohistorical analysis,
and that was that.
So whenever people
ask me, like I
get a lot of emails
and questions,
especially from women like
mid-age like me, who tell me,
how did you switch?
Why did you switch?
Should I switch?
And they feel like
there's so much risk.
I always say like,
do it yesterday,
because you think you may
not want to do something
that you don't
know anything about
but that you're
really attracted to,
and just the fact that
you're really attracted to it
and you can't stop
thinking about it,
and you're sacrificing
a path that you already
took for going in that, is
going to make you give it all
you've got.
And you're going to come
from a different perspective.
Like if I had started
cooking when I was 18,
I wouldn't be talking
about legends and histories
and traditions and sort of
the political nerve of where
the recipes come from.
And so I think-- but
you didn't ask me that.
You asked me when I
went into cooking,
so then I went into cooking,
and then I went into cooking.
And my cooking has
really changed.
LEE KEENER: We have another
question over there.
PATI JINICH: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH].
Thank you so much
for coming to Google.
I remember as a
kid in Michoacan,
my grandmother--
meat wasn't always
something that was
readily available,
so she was very
inventive with vegetables
and especially trying to
get kids to eat vegetables.
What are some of the
vegetarian options
for enchiladas that
you recommend--
healthier, vegetarian stuff?
PATI JINICH: Yes.
I love that question.
I have a very good friend in
Washington, Joe Yonan, who
is the Washington Post
food and travel editor,
and he became a
vegetarian very recently.
And he had a really,
really funny article
in the Washington
Post saying how
it was harder for
him to come out
as a vegetarian
being a food writer
than when he came
out as being gay.
And it was an
incredible article.
And because being a
food writer, people
will question, well,
how can you review this,
or how can you review
that if you're not?
So anyway, I've had these
conversations with him,
because we sometimes
cook together,
and I'm always telling
him, and this with meat,
and this with chicken,
and this with chorizo.
And I did a detox-- I know
you asked me something,
and I'm getting there.
I did a detox like two
years ago with my husband.
I eat absolutely everything.
And like two years
ago, we did a detox,
just because to see-- because
everybody was doing it.
Some friends were doing it.
Just to feel how our body
would react like for two weeks,
and it was two weeks
of, you know, nothing.
I mean no meat, no poultry, no
lactose, no wine, no coffee,
no-- just grains,
vegetables, fruits.
And for three days, I
was really mean, really
mean, because I drink
a lot of coffee.
But then I felt fabulous.
I felt great.
And then slowly, we
started adding food groups
into our diet, and
it's like my system
got completely recalibrated.
And I now hunger much more
the vegetables, the fruits,
the grains, the vegetarian
options, and the funny thing
is that Mexican cuisine
has naturally always
been very vegetarian.
Before the Spanish
arrived a long time ago,
there was mainly vegetables,
fruit, grains, seeds.
If there was any animal
protein, it was fish
or it was wild turkey like
the pig, the beef, the lamb,
the cheese, the milk, like
all the lard, all of that
came with the Spanish.
So if you go into Mexico's
countryside, most of the diet
that you find is vegetarian--
the moles, the stews,
the soups, the
enchiladas, everything
are heavily based
on ingredients.
And as I was telling
Joe, because he just
wrote an article about the
vegetarian options in my book,
and I was telling him, the funny
thing is in Mexico and the US,
things are experienced so
differently in that here, it's
been very trendy, you
know, the vegetarian
and vegan and organic
and from farm to table
and all those concepts and
artisanal are like so new--
well, maybe not so
new-- but recent.
In Mexico, we've had
farm to table always.
The farmers' markets
are the markets.
The farmers are
the markets always,
and it's not the exclusive
or fancy thing to do.
It's the cheapest, more
affordable thing to do.
And Mexico has naturally been
very veggie and grain-based,
but we haven't called them that.
So now that it's gotten
to be very trendy,
it's like many of our
recipes and dishes
we're starting to put them in
that box just in that concept.
I'm going to answer.
I have-- like there, one
of my favorite things
is refried bean and plantain
taco, and the plantains
you just stick in the
oven with the whole peel
until they come out,
and they caramelize,
and they're super soft.
And they contrast with the
very earthy refried bean
and the plantains, which
are sweet and caramelized.
It's delicious.
And then I top it with
like walnut seed crunch
like walnut, pumpkin seeds,
sunflower seeds, scallions,
jalapenos just cooked
like for two minutes.
It's so incredible.
I'm going to show you the
photo after we're done.
But the funny thing
is I didn't start--
in talking about how I've
evolved in my cooking-- it's
like in the last
three years, I've
cooked a lot more vegetarian.
So there's like Swiss
chard and potato enchiladas
with Hatch chili sauce.
There's like asparagus and
mushroom enchiladas a pine nut
mole sauce.
There's like a
vegetarian posole verde.
I mean, you can practically
make the entire book vegetarian.
If in the soups, instead
of using chicken broth,
you use vegetable broth, there's
a hearts of palm soup in there
to die for.
I know, because I made it.
Anyway, tons of options.
AUDIENCE: Any other questions?
PATI JINICH: Because now they
know if they ask me something,
I'm going to answer
something else.
Nothing?
No?
AUDIENCE: How did
you get on PBS?
PATI JINICH: Oh,
that's a good question,
but that's a long
question again.
I was pitched to
the Food Network
many years ago like
seven or eight years ago,
when I started with the culinary
program at the Mexican Cultural
Institute with
something like this,
but I focus more on
what I say, because I'm
more familiar with the
place, like eight years ago.
And a lot of people
started coming,
and word started
spreading a little
about the classes
and the content,
and I started to get
invited like to some radio
things or local TV
things, and word spread.
And somebody did a pilot and
pitched me to the Food Network.
And they said, yay, we love it.
Let's buy a season of
this, but your hair
could be a little bit more red.
Maybe you can get a dog.
Maybe instead of buying Mexican
food, you do Latin food.
And most of all.
Let's get rid of your accent.
And so I thought, well, if
instead of doing Mexican, which
is what I know, I do Latin, and
if I get rid of my accent, then
who will I become?
Like after I do a few seasons
here or something, which
would have been
great, of course,
but then I think you do sort
of a sense of who you are
and what you do.
So some people from
the local PBS station
had come to my classes,
and they said, you know,
it would be really great to
have a Mexican do Mexican food.
We like your accent.
We love your content, because
you had a lot of history
and a lot of backbone
to it, and it'd
be great to have a
Mexican do Mexican food,
and that's what prompted it.
And then it took a
few years, of course,
and then we're going
to our fifth season
now, which will be
out in September.
AUDIENCE: Congratulations.
PATI JINICH: Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, I think the
enchiladas are there.
LEE KEENER: Dante,
ladies and gentlemen.
AUDIENCE: Pati, I have
a question for you.
PATI JINICH: Yes, anything.
AUDIENCE: So to address the
tortilla, which I was really
excited to see you make this.
I've been making
enchiladas for awhile now.
Whenever I've done
it, and you mentioned
that you can have the
option of flash frying it,
and then putting
it in the sauce.
Is there a method
that you prefer?
I've never actually seen
anyone do it this way.
PATI JINICH: With the oil?
AUDIENCE: No, with
just burning it.
PATI JINICH: Just heat it.
You know what?
It's really alternative methods.
They both work.
They taste a little
bit different.
What you're doing
is you're making
the tortilla be
resilient, because when
you pass the tortilla
through very, very hot oil
just for like a
few Mississippis,
you're giving it like a nutty--
first, you're adding flavor.
You're giving it a
nutty layer, and you're
making it a little bit crisp.
And then you can roll it.
You've seen that method.
So for people that don't
want to fry the tortillas
or pass the tortilla
through oil,
you just need to either put them
over the fire or a hot comal
or skillet, and you just wait
until the tortilla slightly
browns and becomes malleable.
What happens is that the
tortilla, just like the pita
pocket or the pita
bread, when you heat it,
the space between the two
layers of the tortilla
will fluff a little.
And that's what makes the
tortillas not break or crumble.
And also, I don't know
how to explain it,
but it wakes up-- it makes the
flavors of the ingredients sort
of come alive.
And so you can use either
method-- through the oil,
or heat it over
the fire or comal.
Don't use the microwave.
Do one by one.
It doesn't take long.
You can use a big
surface, and then just
heat many tortilla
at the same time,
and then you can pack them
up in a kitchen towel,
and they become
resilient for you.
But if you put them all together
from the bag in aluminum
foil, in the oven,
or in the microwave,
you've destroyed
those tortillas.
I mean they're just going
to stick to one another.
They're going to become
muggy and moist and humid.
And it's going to be
hard to separate them,
and they're not going
to roll, and you're
going to hate me for
trying to make enchiladas.
Of course.
Anybody?
Anything?
AUDIENCE: So now I
have the curiosity
of who got the ceviche
first-- Peru or Mexico?
PATI JINICH: You know what?
Just like the-- that's
a great question.
Yeah.
Talk about a question that made
someone change their career.
It is so funny, and I
still laugh to the day
with Michael, who's the
president of the think tank.
You know, when I resigned,
he wasn't thrilled at all,
but we're very close friends.
But every time somebody asked
me about my change of career,
and I say that I wasn't
happy at the think tank,
he keeps telling me, thank
you for saying that my think
tank made you miserable, and
it's a horrible dreadful place.
It's a wonderful place.
Just like the tres
leches cake, the ceviche
is sort of regional.
It belongs to all
of Latin America.
When did the first
person eat raw fish?
So it's about the same time one
could assume that people were
eating raw fish and
adding ground chilies
or salt to preserve them
or to give them taste
or because humans--
we've always needed salt.
And then when it really
turned them into ceviche
was when that citrus was added.
And when the boats got here with
Spanish and Portuguese people
and the Moors that had
the citrus, I mean,
I guess-- I think Mexico, but
I think the ceviches from Peru
are really extraordinary too.
I'll give them that.
LEE KEENER: They get the credit.
PATI JINICH: Are you Peruvian?
LEE KEENER: It's
just what you hear.
Most people think-- but
to answer your question--
I know you asked her and
not me, but your question
about the vegetarian food.
The cuisine is the land.
It's what is from there, and
when we're researching menus,
everything we find is that
there's such an amalgam
of so many different things.
Everywhere is a melting pot.
It depends how far back you go.
So what is traditional
Mexican food?
It's what is in front of you
is in the ingredients that
are from there.
So you can change,
you can experiment,
you can make it your own.
It's not always about
just removing the meats
and adding in beans or grain
or something like that.
PATI JINICH: I agree.
And also the question of
authentic and traditional-- I
know nobody asked, but
going to that topic--
I think just like
artisanal, you know,
now you go to McDonald's,
and they tell you
that the bread is artisanal.
I think those concepts
have unfortunately
been so overused
in what's authentic
and what's traditional.
I think everything, if not
mostly everything that's
considered traditional
Mexican food, was once fusion,
because in Mexico,
there was no rice.
There was no pasta.
There was no onion.
There was no garlic.
So even though it's
a recent concept,
I think the strong
cuisines have the power
to embrace new
ingredients and have
their own strong interpretation.
But I agree with you that
you can drive through Mexico,
and I think now that
Mexican cuisine has really
become borderless, because
I think you can find just
as extraordinary Mexican
food here in Chicago
as in Michoacan.
And it's just different
spins and different regional
takes that have to do with what
Mexican communities find here
in Chicago.
So they come with
their techniques
and their ingredients
and their know-how
that they love, and they
know-- like your abuela.
I know you were telling me.
But then you move to Chicago,
and you have all of these,
and then you learn
to love the things
that you find in your new home.
And you sort of weave
them into what you know.
Is that Mexican?
I say 100%.
But there's a good
debate, though.
LEE KEENER: Pati,
thank you so much.
We really appreciate
you being here.
PATI JINICH: Thank you.
Thank you for having me here.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.